Sammeln und deutlich buchstabieren.
Ja, der Vorname ist P-A-U-L Paul.
Und der Familienname ist M-Y-N-D-E-R.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 69 und werde dieses Jahr 70. geboren am 18.09.56.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin 1,74.
74. Ok, wissen Sie wie viel Sie wiegen?
Wie bitte?
Wissen Sie wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, also immer so um die 83, 84 Kilo.
83. Ok.
Was willst du denn heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe eine komische Stelle am Bein.
Die ist schon, ja ich habe da schon lange, aber jetzt ist es mit einem mal so schlecht geworden.
Und zwar, da habe ich mich mal verletzt.
Beim Fahrradfahren bin ich so abgerutscht und da habe ich jetzt immer so eine kleine Stelle, eine kleine offene Stelle.
Und jetzt wird die aber immer größer.
Und jetzt tut sie auch richtig weh.
Und was mich wirklich so ein bisschen erschreckt hat, da läuft jetzt mit einem mal so komische Flüssigkeit raus.
Und ich wollte eigentlich zu meinem Hausarzt gehen, aber der hat jetzt Urlaub während der Feiertage.
Und deswegen habe ich da keinen erreicht und habe gesagt, dann komme ich doch lieber zu Ihnen, bevor das jetzt mit den Feiertagen losgeht.
Denn das sieht gar nicht schön aus.
Und das ist auch ganz dick und spannend, das Bein.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben, Herr Wiminda.
Und Sie haben die richtige Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Aber ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden wieder zusammenfassen.
Sie haben einen Fahrradunfall erlebt.
Nein, das ist schon ganz lange her, da bin ich nur mal so ein bisschen dagegen gestoßen gegen die Pedale.
Und dann gab es halt so eine kleine offene Stelle.
Das ist schon lange, das ist im letzten Herbst gewesen, Ende des Sommers.
Das ist schon Monate her.
Und seither ist es nie richtig zugeheilt.
Und jetzt wird es mit einem mal so viel größer und das Bein schwillt an.
Und jetzt nässt es eben so und da läuft so richtig die Soße runter.
Das ist ganz furchtbar.
Das habe ich verstanden.
Und wo genau diese Verletzung?
Ja, das ist am rechten Bein unten, ja am Knöchel innen.
Beim Knöchel und Knochen.
Okay, das habe ich gut verstanden.
Und danach leiden Sie diese ungeheilten Wunden.
Und deswegen sind Sie hier.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Jaja, klar.
Und weil das so dick und blau ist, das Bein, das sieht ganz schrecklich aus.
Dick und blau, okay.
Ja, Herr Minder, seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Ich meine die Wunden.
Seit Herbstferien oder seit Kürzen?
Nein, seit letztem Herbst.
Das ist bestimmt schon mehr als ein halbes Jahr.
Halbes Jahr, okay.
Das habe ich verstanden.
Und leiden Sie auch Schmerzen in diesem Stelle?
Ja, also das war bisher nicht so schlimm.
Aber jetzt wird es eben so unangenehm.
Und es tut richtig weh.
Und das Bein spannt eben auch so.
Okay.
Und die andere Teil Ihres Beins, sind die gerötet, gewärmt oder nur diese Stelle?
Ja, es ist ganz prall und blau.
Prall und blau, okay.
Und haben Sie keine Schmerzen in dieser Stelle?
Haben Sie Fieberstöße?
Nein, jetzt habe ich Schmerzen.
Natürlich habe ich Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala, wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ja, aber kann das ja aushalten?
Also würde in der Mitte sagen, so bei 5.
Könnten Sie das aushalten?
So ein aushalten bis zum Ende des Gesprächs oder brauchen Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe das schon so lange.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Stichend, brennend oder das konnte ich nicht gut verstehen.
Deswegen möchte ich...
Ja, ich habe das auch noch nicht.
Schmerzen beschreiben ist so schwierig.
Ja, also jetzt sticht es schon und diese Spannung, das ist so ein Druckgefühl.
Druckgefühl?
Stichend beschreibt es ganz gut.
Und je nachdem, wenn man da irgendwo gegenkommt, dann brennt es natürlich auch diese offene Stelle.
Und es gibt...
Flüssigkeit, ja.
Flüssigkeit und die Wunde ist ein Nest.
Und wir oder gibt es eine gestörte Gerüchte mit dieser Wunde?
Was gibt es?
Gerüche, ich meine, stinkt das?
Stinkt die Wunde?
Ja, stinkt das?
Also ich habe das jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Und meine Frau hat sich auch nicht beschwert.
Also ich denke mal, das riecht nicht, würde ich sagen.
Okay, die Farbe und ich würde gerne wissen, die Farbe dieser Sekret oder dieser Flüssigkeit.
Ja, das ist freundlich.
Das ist braunlich.
Ja.
Okay, das habe ich notiert.
Danke für all diese Informationen.
Sie sind sehr wichtig für uns, eine richtige oder genaue Diagnose zu stellen.
Und waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Ja, das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Okay, nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Haben Sie eingenommen?
Nein, am Anfang habe ich da mal Pflaster drauf gemacht
und dann habe ich mal ein bisschen Salbe drauf geschmiert, so ein bisschen Fettcreme.
Aber das hat ja alles nicht geholfen.
Okay, was für eine Salbe haben Sie darauf aufgetragen?
Ja, so eine Fettsalbe, damit es irgendwie besser wird.
Aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stellfrost, Nacktschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht krank.
Okay, haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Atemnot oder Herzrasen?
Nein, ich komme wegen meines Beines.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen, aber manchmal gibt es zusammenhänge.
Es kann zusammenhangen in dem ganzen Körper.
Zusammenhänge geben.
Ja, geben, deswegen habe ich danach gefragt oder muss ich danach fragen.
Okay, ist Ihnen übel oder müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein, mein Magen ist ganz in Ordnung.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, zum Glück noch nicht.
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Also manchmal bin ich ein bisschen verstopft.
Verstopft.
Ja, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich gut.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter, Herr Münder?
Wo leide ich darunter?
Ja, ich meine Appetitlosigkeit.
Sie haben das erwähnt.
Ich habe guten Appetit.
Guten Appetit, okay, das habe ich falsch verstanden.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Also so viel ich weiß.
Also eigentlich passen alle Hosen und ich wiege mich auch nicht so wie jeden Tag.
Aber hin und wieder mal, das ist eigentlich stabil, immer frei.
Und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
So ganz gut schlafe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ja, das habe ich notiert.
Und gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden, ich meine diese Schmerzen und diese Druckgefühl verstärkt oder lindert?
Zum Beispiel Körperverlegerung oder Hochlage, meine ich, in Ihrem Bein.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, ist das Bein nicht ganz so prall und dick.
Und wenn ich dann aber aus dem Bett aufstehe und ins Badezimmer gehe, dann schießen die Schmerzen natürlich so richtig rein.
Sie haben kein Fieber, das ist auch wichtig.
Und Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, Atemnot oder ähnliche Beschwerden.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel
chronische Erkrankungen wie Blutzuckerkrankheit oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Also bisher, das einzige was ich weiß, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Und ja, ich trage halt ein Hörgerät und deswegen habe ich immer wieder Mittelohrentzündung.
Mittelohrentzündung, leiden Sie da, oder?
Wie oft leiden Sie daran? Ich meine die Mittelohrentzündung.
Ja, also zuletzt war das vor drei Wochen.
Vor drei Wochen?
Ja, das kommt eigentlich immer wieder, also vielleicht alle zwei Monate oder so.
Alle zwei Monate leiden Sie daran.
Okay, das ist auch wichtig für uns.
Und Sie leiden an arterieller Bluthochdruck.
Ja, genau.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Oh, das hat man so vor 10, 12 Jahren festgestellt.
Okay, und ich denke, die Blutdruckmessungen sind normal.
Habe ich richtig verstanden.
Mit Geräte, Sie haben es gerade erwähnt.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, ich habe Blutdruck und deswegen muss ich halt Medikamente nehmen.
Okay, das habe ich.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Also ich nehme HCT.
Ich weiß gar nicht wofür das ist und Zufenopril.
Zufen... Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
HCT und Zufenopril.
Zufenopril, Zufenopril, okay.
Das habe ich notiert.
Wie war die Dosierung?
Könnten Sie sich daran erinnern?
Bei Zufenopril, das ist 5.
Ich weiß nicht was.
Und dann muss ich morgens und abends eine nehmen.
Zweimal.
HCT 25 nehme ich morgens eine.
HCT 25 nehmen Sie morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch Aspirin.
Eine am Mittag.
So eine Aspirin 100.
Aus welchem Grund nehmen Sie Aspirin?
Das ist schon ewig lange, hat mein Hausarzt mir irgendwann mal empfohlen, dass das gut wäre.
Damit man die Blutgerinnung verbessert.
Ja genau.
Seit ich eine Thrombose hatte.
Ich hatte in dem rechten Bein vor 5 Jahren eine Thrombose.
Vor 5 Jahren leidest du.
Das ist sehr wichtig für mich diese Information.
Danke für die Information.
Und dann habe ich erst so ein Makuma bekommen.
Und dann, als ich nach einem halben Jahr, hat der Hausarzt dann gesagt, ich könnte diese Aspirin nehmen.
Ich möchte das zusammenfassen.
Vor 5 Jahren hatten Sie eine Thrombose im rechten Bein.
Genau.
Deswegen haben Sie damals dagegen ein Makuma.
6 Monate lang.
Danach, dieser Makuma wurde ausgesetzt.
Ja.
Ok, das habe ich verstanden.
Und ich meine, danach diese Beschwerden, hatten Sie Probleme damit?
Da hätte ich mehr.
Ok.
Und jetzt sind Sie hier mit einem rechten Bein Problem.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Ich wüsste nicht.
Keine Operation?
Nein, als Kind nicht.
Ok.
Und jetzt, nein, die letzten Jahre zum Glück auch nicht.
Danke.
Und sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt, Herr Minder?
Ja, ich darf keine Meeresfrüchte essen, also keinen Fisch, keine Muscheln, keine Krabben und diese ganzen Geschichten da.
Da habe ich einmal eine heftige Reaktion bekommen und das war fast so, dass ich dann auch keine Luft mehr bekommen habe und so.
Und dann gab es mal eine Handgräbe, auf die ich reagiert habe, die habe ich nicht vertragen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nur bei einer Sorte gewesen.
Sie haben mehr Frühstücke Allergie und diese Allergie äußert sich mit Handgräben und Atemnotproblemen.
Ja, genau.
Ok.
Das ist auch für mich wichtig.
Und haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Minder?
Meeresfrüchte vertrage ich nicht halt.
Aber sonst?
Das habe ich als Allergie.
Ok.
Und Herr Minder, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Früher habe ich geraucht, aber seit 18 Jahren rauche ich jetzt schon nicht mehr.
18 Jahre, ok.
Früher habe ich im Päckchen am Tag schon geraucht, ja.
20 Päckchen am Tag.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie gratulieren, weil Sie damit aufgehört haben.
Aber das wäre genug, ja.
Seit 18 Jahren rauchen Sie nicht.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
20 Zigaretten, Sie haben eben schon erwähnt.
Ja, bestimmt 30 Jahre lang.
30 Jahre, ok.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Minder?
Gelegentlich trinke ich mal ein Bier und wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, trinkt man auch mal ein Sekt oder auch mal ein Schnäpschen oder so.
Aber eigentlich eher selten.
Also Bier schon ziemlich regelmäßig, aber...
Was meinen Sie mit regelmäßig?
Ja, vielleicht so zweimal in der Woche oder dreimal in der Woche.
Und im Sommer, wenn es heiß ist, auch mal eins mehr.
Und Sekt? Wie oft?
Ja, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt.
Feiern, feiern.
Feiert man nicht Geburtstag oder Weihnachten oder was auch immer, ja.
Das habe ich verstanden.
Herr Minder, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben?
Ich mit Drogen? Nein.
Also wirklich nicht. Drogen habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ja, gut zu hören. Vielen Dank.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Ja, also bei der Arbeit ja Gott sei Dank nicht mehr. Ich bin der Rentner.
Und zu Hause ist es natürlich schon ein bisschen stressig.
Meine Frau hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Und sie ist also sehr kränklich und die ist auch nicht mehr mobil.
Die sitzt im Rollstuhl überwiegend.
Und da muss ich natürlich viel helfen und für sie da sein.
Ja, das ist schön das zu hören. Danke.
Ja, Frau, Herr Minder.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit aus dem Land oder aus dem Ausland?
Aus dem Ausland? Nein, aus dem Ausland waren wir nicht.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder haben Sie Probleme?
Ja, meine Eltern leben natürlich schon nicht mehr. Ich bin ja schon so alt.
Und mein Vater, ja, der hatte, was ganz komisch ist, der hatte in den Gallengängen
irgendwie Tumore und ja, der ist also gar nicht so alt geworden.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte auch Darmprobleme und hat dann noch
einen künstlichen Darmausgang bekommen und ja, die war aber dann auch schon
86, als sie verstorben ist.
Es tut mir leid, das habe ich nicht gut verstehen.
Ihre Mutter hat dann Probleme, deswegen oder was für ein Problem hat sie?
Ja, sie hatte eine schwere Darmerkrankung und brauchte einen künstlichen Darmausgang.
Oder war das Krebs oder? Das weiß ich gar nicht genau.
Oder eine chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung.
Ich kann Ihnen das nicht sagen.
Ja, ist sie daran verstorben?
Ja, letztendlich war sie alt.
Dann kommt ja dann immer alles zusammen.
Ok, Sie sind Rentner und was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich war Angestellter in der Verwaltung.
Angestellter in der Verwaltung.
Und Sie sind verheiratet, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie und sind Sie gesund?
Zwei Kinder, die sind gesund, ja.
Herr Münder, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerde habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Wundheilungsstörung bei Ihnen.
Höchstwahrscheinlich wegen Ihren vorherigen Gefäßproblemen am Bein, am rechten Bein.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Verengung oder Verschluss in Ihrem Bein.
Und was kann man dagegen machen?
Bein gefälscht, ja.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deswegen muss ich weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich die körperlichen Untersuchungen etwas Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Und ich werde eine EKG schreiben, um eine mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Kann das was mit dem Herzentreton haben?
Ja, als luthinemäßig und wichtiges Verfahren sollten wir das machen.
Und als wichtige Untersuchung werde ich Ihren Bein mit Ultraschall untersuchen.
Ist das denn weh?
Nein, das ist eine schmerzfreie Methode, die etwa 10 oder 15 Minuten dauert.
Damit können wir Ihre Gefäße richtig und genau beurteilen, ob es Probleme gibt.
Praktisch und häufig verwendet.
Sie brauchen keine Angst.
Aber sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen, beschaue ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Das klingt gut.
Bitte warten Sie hier und ich komme gleich.
Wunderbar.
Möchte jemand noch eine Frage stellen?
Er hat wirklich sehr vollständig gefragt und war sehr geduldig, oder?
Das sieht er glaube ich gar nicht, dass er hier die ganzen Applauskurven kriegt.
Darf ich fragen?
Aber natürlich.
Wie groß ist die Wunde?
Oh, weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Wie groß ist die?
Inzwischen ist die vielleicht so groß wie ein Eurostück.
Dankeschön.
Darf ich fragen?
Immer.
Können Sie das Bein normal bewegen? Haben Sie ein Taubheitsgefühl oder Krippen?
Das habe ich verstanden, ob ich es bewegen kann.
Ich kann das Bein bewegen, aber es tut mir ein bisschen weh, weil es so gespannt ist.
Und das andere war die Frage, habe ich nicht verstanden.
Haben Sie Krippen oder Taubheitsgefühl?
Ein Taubheitsgefühl, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Nein, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich.
Haben Sie bemerkt eine Überwärmung im betroffenen Bereich?
Ja, ein bisschen warm fühlt sich das Bein an.
Überwärmung, ja?
Dankeschön.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, gerne.
Herr Ninder, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Oh Gott, das ist schon so lange her.
Aber alles, was man als alter Mensch haben muss, diese Corona-Impfung habe ich gemacht.
Und die Grippe-Impfung habe ich auch gemacht.
Und dann diese Impfung gegen Lungenentzündung, das soll man ja auch irgendwie so eine Impfung machen.
Ach, habe ich alles und hier.
Ganz scheußlich war das mit der Gürtelrose.
Ja, mein Hausarzt, der ist, was das Impfen angeht, der ist ganz fit.
Ich möchte wissen, insbesondere gegen Tetanus.
Nochmal bitte?
Ich möchte wissen, besonders gegen Tetanus.
Ach so, Tetanus.
Tetanus, das macht man ja nur, wenn man sich irgendwie im Garten verletzt hat oder so.
Aber das habe ich auch mal gehabt, aber das ist bestimmt schon lange her.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ob ich Geschwister habe?
Sind Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Brüder, aber ich habe da wenig Kontakt eigentlich mit denen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe noch einen.
Ja, da ist noch jemand, der fragen möchte.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie ein Hörgerät tragen.
Aus welchem Grund tragen Sie Hörgerät?
Und auf welcher Seite haben Sie Mittelohrenentzündung?
Ja, also ich habe das Hörgerät links, weil ich schlecht höre.
Also große Probleme gehabt habe, gemerkt, dass ich nicht mehr gut verfolgen kann, wenn gesprochen wird.
Und da habe ich auch diese Mittelohrenentzündung immer wieder.
Darf ich fragen?
Gerne.
Leider habe ich es nicht verstanden, wo genau diese Wunde ist.
Am linken Innenknöchel? Quatsch, am rechten Innenknöchel.
Rechten Innenknöchel.
Okay, meine Löhne.
Also Fußgelenk unten.
Okay, danke.
Das waren ja heute viele Fragen.
Aber ich freue mich immer, weil ich das Klasse finde, dass Sie alle richtig gut dabei sind und engagiert mitarbeiten.
Das macht richtig Spaß, mit der Gruppe hier zurzeit zu arbeiten.
Und im Augenblick ist es gerade für mich ein ganz schönes Bild, weil ich so viele bunte Kleckse sehe.
Jeder hat eine andere Farbe und einige haben ja auch keine Bilder oder so etwas.
Aber es ist gerade so ein schönes, buntes Bild.
Bei Ihnen wahrscheinlich auch.
Herr Dr. Dogan, wie weit sind Sie denn?
Ich kann versuchen, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob mein Verdachtdiagnose oder die Veranstaltung wichtig ist.
Ganz viel anderes kann es ja nicht sein.
Da ist eine technische Kleinigkeit, wenn Sie stark nach unten gucken, ist das Mikro nicht gut.
Wenn Sie nach oben gucken, kann ich Sie besser hören.
Ja?
Ist es sowieso netter, wenn Sie mich angucken.
Sollten Sie auch in der Funktion machen.
Wegen dieser technischen Probleme konnte ich nicht.
Aber wenigstens haben wir nicht die gleichen Probleme wie beim letzten Mal.
Das hat mir so leid getan für die Kollegin, die da betroffen war,
weil das wirklich die ganze Anamnese total murkig gemacht hat.
Und ich bin sehr froh, dass wir diese technischen Probleme heute nicht haben.
Gut, ja, dann legen Sie los.
Ja, guten Tag, Frau Wichmann.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte diese Patientin berichten.
Über diese Patientin.
Diesen Patientin berichten, darf ich vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Es geht um Paul Münder.
Er ist 69 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 18.9.1956.
Er ist 1,74 Meter groß und wiegt 83 Kilogramm.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit sechs Monaten bestehender Heilungsstörm.
Oder ungeheilte Wunden.
Und Schmerzen.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind die Schmerzen,
sind diese Beschwerden nach einer Verletzung mit Fahrrad aufgetreten.
Und seit Langem, seitdem leiden sie darunter.
Und warum ist er jetzt gekommen?
Wie bitte?
Warum ist er dann ausgerechnet jetzt gekommen?
Ja, weil die Wunde nicht rechtzeitig oder nicht geheilt ist.
Ja, gut, da hätte man ja schon längst kommen können.
Aber was war denn los mit der Wunde?
Ja, weil die Wunde sich entzündet.
Kann ich so sagen.
Okay, was hat er denn für Beschwerden?
Der Patient bemerkt, dass die Wunde eine braune Flüssigkeit hat.
Und nicht gut riecht.
Und auch eine geschwollene und gerotete Beine bemerkt hat.
Und deswegen ist die Prälung...
Und ist die Wunde immer noch so groß wie am Anfang?
Ja, nein, das war kleiner.
Aber die Wunde ist im Laufe der Zeit größer geworden.
Oh, das ist natürlich doof.
Ja, das ist auch ein Grund für die Patientin, hierher zu kommen.
Und der Patient berichtet, dass diese Schmerzen in linken Knochen lokalisiert werden.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich die Größe dieser Wunde...
Sagen Sie nochmal, wo die lokalisiert ist. Wo ist die Wunde?
In den Knochen. Linken Knochen.
Knochen heißt das?
Nein, nein, linken Bein.
Genau, Lokalisation meine ich.
Das habe ich vielleicht falsch verstanden. Linken Bein?
Nein, also am rechten Bein?
Rechten oder links?
Rechten Bein Trombose, aber linken Bein.
Rechte Bein Trombose, rechte Bein Ulcus.
Also die Wunde am rechten Innenknochen.
Innenknochen, ja.
Innenknochen heißt das. Und irgendjemand hat schon den Fachbegriff Maleolus.
Maleolus medialis. Ja, Mediale, Maleolus.
Ich soll es so sagen natürlich.
In diesem Bereich.
Beim Klassiker.
Ja, und die Schmerzinterstate liegt 5 von 10 auf der NRS.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen drückend.
Außerdem erwähnt er, dass er vor fünf Jahren eine Trombose im Bein, rechten Bein oder TVT im Recht erlitten hat.
Deswegen hat er sechs Monate lang Marcuma eingenommen.
Danach, reibungslos.
Danach hatte er kein Problem damit.
Und Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich Verstopfung und Müdigkeit.
Fachbegriff?
Absipation natürlich.
In diesem Dorf möchte ich manchmal nicht fach werden.
Deswegen habe ich es so gesagt.
Fertigung und Absipation.
Fertigung nicht.
Oder nicht Fertigung.
Insomnie?
Wie bitte?
Insomnie, Entschuldigung.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit zwölf Jahren an arteriärer Hypertonie.
Keine Operationen hat er berichtet.
Der Patient nimmt HCT 25 mg morgens täglich und so fin opril 5 mg morgens und abends täglich.
Und auch Aspirin 100 mg morgens.
Der Patient hat mehres Frühstück Allergie, die sich durch Parastese und Düstne äußert.
Bei der Noxon-Anamnese berichtet der Patient über einen Nikotinkonsum von 30 Pekias.
Seit 18 Jahren ist er nicht Raucher und den Konsum von zwei Gläsern Bier pro Woche und gelegentlich Sekt-Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Kola-Geokarzinom beim Vater und unbekannte Darmerkrankungen bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnistisch ist er Rentner. Früher hat er als Angestellter an der Verwaltung gearbeitet.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Was vermuten Sie denn jetzt?
Nach den anmnistischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Wundheilungsstörung im Rahmen TVT.
Dafür sprechen verspätete Heilungsprozesse, entzündliche Wunde und die Vorgeschichte des Patienten mit TVT.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt unkontrolliert.
Aber diese Frage wurde nicht gestellt, deswegen kann ich nicht Differenzialdiagnostik Diabet nennen.
Vielleicht nicht erkannt, das könnte durchaus sein.
Ja, das kann sein.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt mit Diabetes und Meditatorzug zu leicht.
Und vielleicht auch Raucherbein.
In meiner Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst natürlich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Besonders das Bein und die Wunderbereich und auch Lunge.
Welche Aspekte nehmen Sie besonders warm?
An den Beinen?
Die Pulse, natürlich. Ich werde die Pulse auf die Pulse achten.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Nur an diesen Beinen?
Die Malolus, meine ich.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Bei beiden Beinen.
Im Vergleich.
Und was gucken Sie noch an?
Allein mit Ihren Augen?
Was sehen Sie mit Ihren Augen?
Ich schaue, ob der Raucherbein gerötet oder geschwollen ist.
Und auch die Wunderflüssigkeit.
Oder die Wundersekret.
Entschuldigung, wo soll ich das nutzen?
Und die Größe der Wunde.
Auch die Hautfarbe.
Ob es blau oder dunkel ist.
Blau oder dunkel, ja.
Und die Wunde.
Worauf gucken Sie da?
Und auch die Tiefe.
Die Wundtiefe?
Das ist auch wichtig.
Wahrscheinlich, ob es eine Ostomialitis gibt.
Also, dass sie so tief geht.
Ja, ja.
Wir haben einmal die Größe der Wunde.
Wir haben potenziell die Tiefe.
Wir haben die Farbe des Beines.
Aber ob es einen Belag gibt auf der Wunde.
Ist das eitrig belegt?
Das ist eitig belegt.
Das muss man auch mit angucken.
Gut.
Und was machen Sie sonst diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Auch die Dopplex-Utrasone.
Ist sehr wichtig, ob es eine Verschluss oder Thrombus gibt.
Das ist eine entscheidende Untersuchungsmethode für uns.
Besonders bei diesem Fall.
Und natürlich im Labor ist auch wichtig.
Was bestimmen Sie im Labor besonders?
Ja, Labor auf jeden Fall eine Wundkultur aus Flüssigkeit.
Wundflüssigkeit oder nehme ich.
Wow, richtig, Abstrich. Sehr gut. Ja.
Aber wir waren gerade bei der Blutuntersuchung.
Welche Blutparameter lassen Sie denn bestimmen?
Ja, ich werde im Labor Blutbild natürlich.
Und auch Entzündungsparameter.
Einschließlich Procalcitonin.
Das ist auch wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Und Leber- und Nierenwerte.
Elektrolyte auch wichtig.
Und Hämoglobin A1C, Blutzucker.
Ob der Unterrichter in versteckten Diabetes hat?
Ja, und auch Entzündungsparameter.
Einschließlich Dedimer.
Und auch L-D-H.
Und ich werde auch bei diesem Fall Blutgasanalyse kontrollieren lassen.
Gegen Laktatspiegel vielleicht.
Ok, gut. Und was würden Sie sonst diagnostisch noch weiter machen?
Sonst kann man eigentlich nicht viel machen.
Ich denke erste Schritte können diese Untersuchungen ausreichend sein.
Und wie wäre denn die Therapie?
Ja, gegebenenfalls kann ich auch CT-Angio veranlassen.
Aber wie gesagt...
In welchem Fall machen Sie das?
Wenn ich meinen Verdacht Diagnose...
Wenn ich nicht richtig...
Bei einem starken Verdacht Diagnose, aber wenn der Fall nicht nachgewiesen ist.
Wenn Sie also keine Gefäßveränderung im venösen Bereich nachweisen können,
sondern vermuten, dass das was Artäielles ist?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Weil einer meiner Verdacht Diagnose Raucherbein ist,
wurde ich auch gegebenenfalls...
Dann macht das CT-Angio Sinn, ne?
Ja, CT-Angio veranlassen auch.
Und sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen,
würde ich diese Patienten auf jeden Fall...
Diese Patienten?
Ja, ja, diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Was machen Sie mit ihm?
Ich werde...
Flüssigkeit zuvor und Elektrolysis-Substitution
auch symptomatisch Antianalgetikum verabreichen oder verordnen.
Und auch nach der Kultur werde ich oder verabreiche ich Antibiotikum.
Wenn wir da einen Erreger drauf haben?
Ja, einen Erreger drauf und kalkuliert.
Und was machen Sie mit der Runde?
Ja, Wundervorsorgung ist sehr wichtig in diesem Fall.
Eine gute oder eine passende Versorgung führe ich durch.
Ja, was ist denn passend bei einer setzernierenden Wunde?
Was brauchen Sie?
Ja, bei diesem Fall die Ampfekt oder Gangrenüse
Teile oder Flüssigkeit, Sekretien entfernen.
Entfernen? Ja, beziehungsweise Sie brauchen eine Wundauflage.
Sie machen die Wunde sauber und danach brauchen Sie eine saugende Wundauflage,
die diese Setzernierung auffängt.
Sie brauchen also einen Multiabsorber.
Und es gibt ja jede Menge Spezialverbände, Verbandmaterial,
Alginatverbände oder Silber, Silber, Oberflächen oder sowas.
Und was machen Sie noch mit dem Bein?
Der Patient nimmt schon Aspirin, 100 mg.
Vielleicht, je nach einer Kardeo- oder Gepätschirurgischen Konsultation,
kann ich die Aspirin-Dosierung auf 300 mg steigern.
Und auch Heparin ist wichtig als antikoagulative Therapie.
Solange er liegt, oder wie? Ja.
Und was machen Sie mit dem Bein noch?
Hochlagerung ist sehr wichtig.
Hochlagerung und Kompression, Entschuldigung.
Die Kompression ist auch bei diesem Fall wichtig,
weil eine mögliche Embollie oder wahrscheinlich Embollie zu vermeiden.
Ja, überhaupt Kompression auch für die Lundheilung, oder?
Ja, auch für die Lundheilung.
Und vielleicht gegebenenfalls, ich habe vergessen,
die Lipidprofil im Labor kontrollieren zu lassen.
Ich werde auch die Lipidprofil kontrollieren lassen.
Entschuldigung.
Wenn der Patient erhöhte Lipid hat,
dann würde ich auch Statin oder Atomastatin,
Cholesterinsenker verabreichen oder verordnen.
Und noch in Teilungsstörung.
Und vielleicht, aber nicht...
Das ist das zweite Mal für diesen Patienten.
Ich meine die TVT-Attacke.
Vielleicht eine Risikofaktor-Einschätzung
kann für diese Patienten oder für die Familienangehörigen
erforderlich sein.
Weil eine mögliche, zukünftige Fehler zu vermeiden.
Dass er regelmäßig einen Kompressionsstrom trägt.
Ich denke mal, wir sind fertig.
Sie unterrichten mich über ihren Patienten.
Wir haben eine spannende Anamnese gehabt.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht,
dass so ein gammeliges Ulcus so eine interessante Diskussion auslöst.
Aber ich fand es total spannend, weil wirklich viele mitgemacht haben.
Es ist zwar kein Düsseldorfer Fall,
das muss ich gerade überlegen.
Ich glaube es ist ein Mainzer Fall.
Ich weiß ja nie, wer kommt.
Das ist immer eine Überraschung für mich.
Aber es kann ihnen immer passieren,
dass ihnen ein Ulcus Krures über den Weg läuft als Hausarzt.
Insofern ist es nicht schlecht, wenn man weiß, was zu tun ist.
Wir haben also zwei Teile ...
Entschuldigung.
Zwei Teile ...
Entschuldigung, mein Gott, ich muss ein Stück trinken.
So, den ersten Teil haben sie sehr souverän gemacht.
Super Anamnese.
Sprachlich sehr schön, immer schön auf den Patienten eingegangen.
Und auch immer wieder bestätigt.
Ich habe das verstanden, was sie gesagt haben.
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Information.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Und als er so ein bisschen ungeduldig war,
als sie nach den anderen Faktoren gefragt haben,
also nach Herz und nach Schwindel oder was auch immer,
das ist trotzdem wichtig für uns, muss ich Sie um Verständnis bitten,
haben sie sehr schön gemacht.
Wir sind dann ins Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch gegangen.
Und da habe ich ein bisschen mehr Unsicherheit bemerkt.
Vor allen Dingen eigentlich in der Beschreibung,
warum der Patient überhaupt gekommen ist.
Sie haben gesagt, der hat seit einem halben Jahr eine Wunde
und jetzt kommt er halt.
Da habe ich als Oberärztin ein bisschen nachgehackt
und habe gedacht, wieso kommt er ausgerechnet jetzt?
Plötzlich ist die Wunde tiefer und größer geworden.
Und mit einmal tut sie weh und mit einmal zerniert sie.
Das hat sie vorher nicht getan.
Also er hat ganz kleine Verschlechterungen da drin.
Das war der Grund, weshalb er gekommen ist.
Was ich witzig finde,
Sie haben mich ja gefragt, wie die Schmerzqualität ist.
Und ich habe gesagt, die ist stechend.
Es sticht und es drückt.
Und Sie haben das einfach nicht erzählt.
Sie haben nur gesagt, es drückt.
Also ich habe Gott sei Dank noch nie ein riesiges Ulchus gehabt,
aber ich glaube, es sticht schon in so einer Runde,
nach allem, was ich so mitgekriegt habe,
das Leute so erzählen.
Dann ist ihm eben auch aufgefallen,
dass das Bein so dick geworden ist und dass das spannt
und dass es dunkelblau verfärbt ist.
Das sind ja alles Gründe, weshalb der gekommen ist.
Mit einmal sieht das Bein ganz furchtbar aus.
Gut.
Dann haben Sie ausdrücklich gefragt,
ob der Patient bemerkt hat, dass das Bein übel riecht.
Und das hat der Phaner gesagt, ich habe nichts gemerkt.
Meine Frau hat auch nichts gemerkt.
Sie schimpft auch nicht, dass ich stinke.
Aber der Oberärztin haben Sie gesagt,
die Wunde ist übel riechend.
Das passt nicht zusammen.
Also haben Sie einfach angenommen, dass die Wunde riecht.
Er hat es aber nicht gesagt.
Haben Sie verstanden?
Ja, ich habe es verstanden.
Gut.
Da waren Sie dann auch bei den Nachfragen
in der Satzkonstruktion und in der Formulierung
nicht so souverän wie am Anfang.
Am Anfang waren Sie beim Arzt-Patient-Gespräch
ganz souverän und haben sehr solide formuliert.
Da gab es eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu meckern.
Da haben Sie ein bisschen geschwommen,
als Sie was frei beschreiben sollten.
Als Sie dann wieder im System drin waren,
als Sie sagen konnten, was weiß ich,
Allergie, da haben Sie diese Hautallergie
gegen eine Handcreme, haben Sie mich erwähnt.
Aber Noxen zum Beispiel, Familienanamnese,
das haben Sie alles dann wieder gut formuliert,
weil es dafür wahrscheinlich Vorformulierungen gibt,
die Sie gut drauf haben und wo Sie dann wieder sicher sind.
Natürlich auch dann in der weiteren Gespräch,
beim Vorgehen in der Untersuchung,
was Sie alles machen müssen.
Das war auch alles dann natürlich völlig souverän.
Auch die Maßnahmen, was man mit den Patienten macht,
kamen alles zusammen.
Wobei das auch wieder nett war,
da haben die Kollegen auch sehr engagiert mitgearbeitet.
Ich fand das richtig schön.
Dieses Ulkos wurde also von vielen Kollegen mitbehandelt.
War ein konsidiarisch behandeltes Ulkos.
Sehr schön.
Aber da haben Sie sich dann wieder wacker geschlagen.
Vielleicht müssten Sie so ein bisschen,
das ist natürlich schwierig, das zu üben,
diese Souveränität einen freien Text zu formulieren.
Da muss man wissen, wie geredet wird.
Das kann man immer nur durch Sprechen lernen.
Sprechen Sie mit Ihren Kindern Deutsch.
Das kann ich Ihnen nur als Tipp geben.
Die können es ja.
Machen Sie Alltagsgespräche auf Deutsch,
damit Sie das üben,
wie Sie eine nicht vorformulierte Geschichte richtig überbringen.
Das war wirklich nur so eine ganz kleine Schwäche.
Ansonsten war es wirklich super.
Gehen Sie munter in Ihre Prüfung, ohne Sorgen.
Wir haben einen interessanten Abend gehabt für mich.
Ich fand es wirklich total gut.
Ich fand es sehr nett, mindestens alle zusammen.
Vielleicht noch ein Punkt.
Ich glaube, die Düsseldorfer sind ziemlich krisch mit der Dauer.
Wir haben ein bisschen,
sowohl bei der Anamnese als auch beim Arztgespräch,
überzogen.
Sie haben ein bisschen länger gebraucht.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist kein Beinbruch.
Insgesamt fand ich, war es wirklich eine gute Geschichte.
Ich fand es sehr nett, die Zusammenarbeit mit Ihnen allen.
Mir hat es viel Spaß gemacht heute Abend.
Damit würde ich mich von Ihnen allen verabschieden für heute.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder.
Dazwischen liegt jetzt eine ganze Serie von Feiertagen.
Danke.
Es liegt eine ganze Serie von Feiertagen vor uns.
Morgen ist bei uns Freitag, ein ganz wichtiger Feiertag.
Dann kommen die Ostertage, unser großes, wunderbares Osterfest.
Ich freue mich sehr darauf.
Dann sehen wir uns alle wieder.
Von mir aus gerne am Dienstag.
Ansonsten genießen Sie die freien Tage.
Tschüss zusammen und schönen Abend für heute.
Schönen guten Halbfeiertag.
Danke, tschüss.
Gute Grüne hier in Ostern.
Danke.